one of the worst affected areas first
time round hit again
they must wonder what further misery is
possible for this region and the people
in it
trauma upon trauma loss and yet more
loss
the hatai mayor has urged residents not
to try returning to their homes few
structures remain intact and those
standing are dangerous
these terrifying moments came after a
fortnight of more than a thousand
tremors
and seismologists warn there'll likely
be more
the gundago family thought they still
had a family home not anymore
the latest set of earthquakes damaged
the roof memet tells us left huge cracks
throughout our home and smashed an
upturned just about everything they
thought they might Salvage
[Music]
they've already suffered huge personal
losses more than 80 family members have
died or are missing
before we had hoped to go back to our
house Fatima tells us there were no
Tremors for two days but now there's
been another big one everything's
falling apart now we've lost all hope we
have none now
she takes us inside the tent they only
got three days ago they've been sleeping
in their car too scared to go anywhere
else well it's just these cushions
really this is all I managed to take
from the house
and just what I'm standing in she says
the millions who fled their homes in
ruined cities across Southern turkey now
fear for their lives in temporary
shelters
wherever they are nothing seems safe
and the aid workers who are helping them
say they need just about everything
right now
we've never witnessed a disaster this
big Jaffa says we've never seen anything
like it before
with so many millions in desperate need
now and an election which could be as
early as May the Turkish president is
facing increasing pressure over why so
many hundreds of thousands of homes
collapse so easily and how a natural
disaster became such a massive tragedy
and just how much of it could have been
averted Alex Crawford Sky News in
Antarctica